noi di solito solo a grandissima
richiesta oggi nuovi giochi foro di
scorso episodio vi è piaciuto tanto è
che provavamo i giochi piccoli brividi
con la bambola parlate con saprete
richards che avevo provato ivy rinascita
ma se non avete visto andate a vederlo
poi dopo questo video oggi proveremo
altri giochi tra cui è unito il nuovo
gioco di the baby in yellow grazie mille
perché ce l'avete detto voi che è uscito
e siete sempre aggiornatissimi molto più
di noi che kakà non ve lo ricordate
abbiamo fatto da baby sitter al mio
figlio di grammy ed era super spaventoso
adesso il sito numero due in cui non è
più un figlio ma è una figlia e una
bambina
vediamo l'ora di provarlo infatti era
bellissimo perché noi abbiamo le stesse
foto stato date anche voi se non mi
seguite ancora stilista che ha mandato a
seguirvi la vanità stories sembra
serviti anche adesso vediamo qui piace a
questo video e se volete vedere un altro
gameplay di cosa hai paura ho sempre nei
tipo carme the recovery e iniziamo a
trovi dario arrivo il gioco pauroso una
casa paurosa stiamo per entrare nella
casa bonus stava consegnando un pacco
siamo un pochino sono entrati dentro
questa casa paurosa dice guardati
intorno vai vicino alla porta
questa curiosa qualcuno ha detto vieni
qua c'è scritto di avvicinarsi alla
finestra giogio il comando marina morgan
ha detto e meglio che ti allontani il
prima possibile
se qualcuno nascosto nel ben qui ha
detto che dobbiamo scappare il prima
possibile e che c'è una chiave nascosta
tra l'altro è che ci aiuterà trovarli mo
risolvere tutti gli indovinelli ed
enigmi per riuscire a scappare da questa
casa ha detto anche di prendere le
monete dentro al castello
poi ha detto che dobbiamo trovare la
chiave nella scrivania
forse non c'è nessuna chiave adeso di
nascondersi nell'armadio perché sta
arrivando qualcuno
chi sarà un altro tipo di grammy che ci
sta cercando
pensavo sommese visto invece no possiamo
uscire adesso
ok meno male funziona paura che ti
beccasse cosa mi farà tre mi beccano un
bastone ha detto non mi ricordo dove la
chiave dai bar sbrigati c'è scritto usa
l'indizio per capire dove la chiave ok
qui
e ovvio dire ha detto che ora possiamo
aprire questa porta e che spera che
riusciremo a scappare si no l'importo
numero di tir rimani qui quindi sia
intrappolato dentro questa stanza ma
perché chi è
voglio sapere tutta la storia proviamo a
te lo porto sarà aperta adesso non
voglio fare un altro imparto a questa
casa è bellissima lo sapete che io adoro
le case horror tipo quelle case giganti
le mansion come fissi italiano mansion
va beh insomma a un test mansion quindi
quelle case i giganti sbirri nate con i
vantaggi aver troppo perfetto per un
nuovo dice ancora dice esploriamo
speriamo in una sorta di grammy in cui
dobbiamo scappare dalla casa però è più
bello perché la casa è più bella e fatta
meglio ci sono un sacco di dettagli però
anche più lui si chiede perché non si
capisce bene cosa bisogna fare terzo
tentativo quanto eviteremo che questa è
l'ultima anche perché
nessuno però spero no forse me lo sono
immaginato attore ci sono veramente
fantastico
io vorrei esplorarla tutta questa casa
troppo bello anche questo è bloccato ma
temo attenti che non arrivano 5 questa
sembra un rapporto di uscita se con
un'altra chiave di grazia ho detto che
ci ha visto dobbiamo scappare da due
scoperte mesi nascondiamo ma si può
andare andiamoci sotto il letto allora
cosa è mancato poco prima che non ci
prenda la stelletta sta scendendo quando
guardate cosa in mano il bastone con la
testa con la testa a forma di testa di
uccello siamo usciti a scamparla questa
volta vede benissimo cosa già colga per
che cosa dobbiamo fare prova a vedere
l'indizio provare delle altre chiavi per
aprire appunto le porte che sono
bloccate quindi proviamo a vedere se
magari sono nascoste in questi cassetti
ma sei sicuro sia sicuro il furto non è
che non è un fantasma va oggi braida
zona
ci ho provato pure sotto l'effetto no
perché abbiamo perso abbiamo perso in
questo gioco quindi passiamo al prossimo
ma scrivete nei commenti se volete che
lo continue continui a lo continueremo
nel prossimo video e lasciati un mi
piace fate mora il prossimo prossimo
gioco a grandissima richiesta
continuiamo il gioco di piccoli brividi
l'abbiamo fatto
nell'altro video abbiamo provato questo
ciò che vi è piaciuto tantissimo di
giorno mi scrivete di così male quindi
ero là continua un'altra volta avevamo
interrotto che entrava il lupo mannaro
infatti eccolo si sta cercando quindi
sicuramente dovremo trovare tutte le
pagine per catturare il lupo mannaro ha
detto che c'è qualcosa che sta facendo
rumore nello studio e non sentite questo
rumor e quindi deve essere qua da
qualche parte rosa però mia pagina
angeli mancano solo sei
stavo paura il tratto troppi ok quale è
entrato entrato qualcuno c'è qualcuno
girati ne andiamo non fa niente
divertente sorridere anche questa casa
la adoro anche se non è una casa antica
come una tipica haunted mansion mai più
una casa moderna e comunque bella perché
un po inquietante paurosa cognome preso
loro lo gnomo aveva rubato un'altra
pagina e noi l'abbiamo rotto e abbiamo
preso la seconda pagina portarmi a
nascondersi sì qualcosa di te noi qui
abbiamo trovato un'altra pagina le
scuole di tina scorso non nascosto dove
siamo sopra non sono saliti a una
soffitta sarà super baura il numero
natation locali sai ha detto o no non
quello mai a donare roma ed a sminare in
pratica siamo quasi al piano di sopra
c'era il baule e abbiamo letto la
formula magica che fa rivivere quei
disse ma chi ha letto quella formula
sicuramente chi ha traslocato qua a
letto quella formula e lo ha fatto torna
in vena e noi ora che l'abbiamo letto
abbiamo fatto tornare in vita di nuovo
qui dobbiamo intrappolarlo nel libro
e team fuochi che ci ha mai preso ha
detto di prenderlo prima che lui prenda
noi ha detto che non era un uomo
amichevole quindi non come gli altri
questi sono cattivi ti sento dei rumori
un po in tanti con l'osso nascondersi
più di nascondersi nelle nasconderselo
giusto in tempo c'è scritto che si sono
clown tristi clown divertenti e clown
molto spaventosi e di non farsi trovare
di fronte a loro perché potrebbe essere
un problema
l'avete visto e c'era un clown che
passava di là e non lottava ameba volta
fa un altro non so come rispondere bene
di avere divano dietro di mano perché
non devo nasconderci dietro divano
questo sopruso gradito dal lupo ma non
mi dire che è stato vicino ha fatto
giusto in tempo perché sarà il
pagliaccio dove niente è come li dovete
uomo non ci credo è arrivato pure lo
zombie lo tentino
quindi ora dobbiamo scappare dal lupo
mannaro dal pagliaccio e dallo zoo mi
sembra normale siamo riusciti a uscire
per un pelo
guarda nella stanza della musica nella
cucina sono le altre pagine le vedete
così tutto il tempo e romano e dentro di
noi il lupo mannaro
eccolo ogni racconto ha bisogno di una
svolta e tu sei la svolta ok ci manca
solo una pagina sì siamo in cui ma
poiché è un uomo home pages nessuno mi
sa che ci sono uno o più pagine forse
qui si hai recuperato tutte le fasi di
ora trova troppi e intrappolano nel
libro la casta la prendono vita polare
non può andare perché troviamo adesso
slap che questa loro sono nascosto sono
andato dai romani si devono ai costi c'è
anche pagliaccio li hai visto
sì sì la vedi la sua non possiamo
vestire la torta volo e penso che più
avanti da il gioco è più mostre si
libereranno dai libri dei piccoli
brividi e quindi saranno tantissimi
volti di tutti assieme che dobbiamo
cercare di ri intrappolare dentro i
libri diventare sempre più difficile
ma è anche divertente e bello paurosa
[Musica]
spostiamoci chi ci sta seguendo ma è
molto lento la cosa per fortuna non ci
siamo riusciti a scappare sarà sta cosa
qui forza non si ferma qui i bagni ma
non è quarta in questo secolo
bravo l'hai trovato lo vedete è lì che
aspetta dobbiamo accendere scappando ok
stiamo ricominciando
ecco non ci sta seguendo troppi ci fosse
un po che ci sono una fan colori meno
cablato di là ora se la luce accesa
quindi dovremo riuscire a intrappolarlo
dentro al lato non riescono a prenderlo
ma mi sto felino si sta ora ho sete
purtroppo avevamo interrotto la
registrazione perché non ci riusciva a
un bar che morcicchia cattura del club
adesso l'obiettivo è raccogliere 8
continueremo nella prossimo episodio
ora dobbiamo provare baby glielo due run
di bra eccoci qua beve glielo due che
hanno chiamato baby liu se questa volta
è una femminuccia
vediamo vediamo
ecco qua capitolo 1 risponde al telefono
sì ha detto sarò via per un po di ore
quindi assicurati di controllare baby ly
rus e del fratellino però forse un
leggermente meno inquietanti le tormente
lo sguardo un po arrabbia trova la
maschera di cesa ok che tipo di maschera
dobbiamo trovare proviamo al piano di
sopra la casa è sempre la stessa è molto
carina anche questa casa dove i piccoli
non c'è qualcuno che gioca benino
ok siamo ad aprire anche questa porta e
vediamo se qui c'è la sua maschera
questa è la nostra camera ecco è una
maschera
ok per chi ha bisogno di questa madre
che era ora di onorare la bottiglie dal
frigo succederà come l'altra volta che
il frigo si trasforma in una sorta di
passaggio bidimensionale si porta in
un'altra dimensione o hanno per fortuna
questa volta perché non succedeva
gommista e felice guarda sta sorridendo
rosse di prendermi portarle a cambiargli
il pannolino e se mi sa che ho fatto una
puzzetta che l'appoggiamo ok quindi
queste come l'altra questa volta quella
cosa la bara di mesto ma noi dobbiamo
darci d'acquisto va bene siamo riusciti
abbiamo alla fine mi è caduto proprio ma
forse dobbiamo dare più c'era qualcosa
dove ecco la festa che lui è molto
arrabbiata che l'hai fatta cadere hard
vede che felice vuol andare a dormire
adesso invece di mettere l'orsacchiotto
nel letto che finora hanno niente di
strano fin ora tutto bene aspettiamolo i
mille luci lei continua a guardarsi modo
inquietante puliamo la bongiorno
speriamo ora che i rustici da nives dice
di andare a giocare al computer
eccoci qua ho l'impressione che troppo
cosa succederà qualcosa di no perché è
molto inquietante questo gioco piangendo
abbiamo trattarla andiamo ma penso che
dobbiamo prendere ma dov'è andata
rubrichette sarà giu franchetti posti
teletrasporta è un no anche qui dov'è e
in cucina a 9 qui ma che ci fai davanti
alla tv perché portiamo nel letto e
forse leggermente meno inquietante del
maschietto baby
perché mi ero dimenticata che c'è tra il
pupazzo qua ok ma ma come io l'ho piano
dopo un lato la musica dove diventò il
primo episodio se non avete visto andate
poi a vederla dopo questa video dopo
dice di prendere la bottiglie dal frigo
e dobbiamo sono sicura che ora
astensione una volta di superstrada
d'aiuto per altra volta presi trasforma
tutto perché prima questo chiuso gli
occhi e ha preso vita forse aspettare
luci tutto bene a iacolare trasportata
nuovamente ti mangia male
ok dice di andare a cambiare l'abbiamo
ricambiare sta per succedere qualcosa
sul singolare che parte forte più brutta
per me è sempre qui dove dove bisogna
cambiare il pannolino mamma erano i
pannolini è scappato e adesso di
inseguirlo
dove seguire il pannolino chi per lui no
era un altro settore sarà brigati prima
che scappi lasciate qui li ha lasciati
qui sta la grandezza di strano no non si
può devi cercare prove dall'altra parte
ok siamo riusciti a spenderle corpus
grammy dov'era finita la bambina salvi
lirio dei mostri
riina portiamolo a dormire ma che
speriamo che faccia e tutto normalissima
detto normalissimo il pupazzo e molto
strano 8 normalissimo questo nome quello
tanto non vedo perché no no no non ci
dobbiamo vedere
no non c'e niente siamo normale perchè
rosso è accaduto a noi dobbiamo spegnere
le luci prima bene io vi la porta
vai a giocare a no andiamo a guardare
alla tv questa volta a proteggere
qualcosa ti ricordi che qui il quadro
l'altra volta era super inquietante cosa
succederà adesso
ok c'è scritto c'è troppo silenzio
secondo e così è sempre sospetto
controlla baby liri effettivamente sta
piangendo ma non c'era troppo silenzio
che ha bisogno di masse d'aria questo
non è questo dice che bisogna del signor
sacchi otto pellicole che questo brutale
questo ci serve più o sono solo telefono
[Musica]
ciao a tutti benissimo forno sono
diversi i 104 si stanno moltiplicando
hanno preso il tetti sono ad una
pacchetto di biblis l'hanno bruciato in
forte dell'aver dice porta baby lyrics
un orsacchiotto tostato dice di trovare
un'arma non ho fatto dei videogiochi
sarà c'è monza predil ha subito questa
dice ok chi dobbiamo affrontare ma
dobbiamo prendere tutti questi gesti
ok bye bye anche con ok ancora si
facevano un altro brano visti abbiamo il
tuo bambino serie b b mi bastano due è
fatto legge di stoppare il rituale come
facciamo l'ultimo tavolo
noi non cerchiamo da qui per governino
verbo berlino
mettiamo un gioiello è sempre super
faticoso fare da baby sitter a questi ma
dove è finita nel frigo
no forse qui è scomparsa non ci credo o
forse si è già seduto
eccola allora mettiamoci qui se
giochiamo insieme video guarda
inquietante
vediamo se siamo riusciti a scendere un
gioco spero di sì perché si sta portando
così ma siamo noi che stiamo guardando è
arrivata la madre e ha detto cos'è
questo caos fini forse se siete qualcosa
di strano sapere nei commenti con è
stato il vostro gioco preferito tra
questi tre per me questo è stato per
divertirsi e ridotto proprio mito
palestro volete che contino vogliate via
stato superato
e allora vi lasciamo qua poi indicare
per vedere inoltre altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite una visione ciao